c'est l'un des nombreux cailloux dans la
chaussure des manuels macron d'après un
sondage fiducial au doxa pour le figaro
62% des français considère comme mauvais
le bilan sécuritaire du chef de l'état
et de son gouvernement
dans le détail l'action du président de
la république est jugée particulièrement
décevante en matière de lutte contre la
délinquance
74% des personnes interrogées l'estiment
mauvaise même son de cloche pour la
lutte contre les trafics de drogue trois
français sur quatre la jugent
insatisfaisantes 71% des sondés jugent
l'action du gouvernement inefficace dans
sa lutte contre les agressions des
personnes ils sont 69% au sujet des
agressions et du harcèlement sexuel pour
le vol de biens et les cambriolages 68%
des personnes interrogées sont
mécontents ils sont 65% à l'être au
sujet du maintien de l'ordre les voyants
virent au rouge sur tous les tableaux
excepté au sujet de la lutte contre le
terrorisme puisque un français sur deux
se dit satisfait du bilan sécuritaire
des manuels macron les français nous
confie à kehl pour la sécurité contrat
dans leur vote en avril 78 % de nos
concitoyens affirment en effet que les
propositions des candidats en la matière
seront importantes au moment de faire
leur choix lorsqu'on leur demande si la
sécurité plus ou moins bien assurée
qu'au début du quinquennat dans certains
lieux les français tire aussi un bilan
négatif des sondages de ce type se
multiplient xala proche de l'élection
présidentielle la finalité est la même
pour tous le bilan sécuritaire des
manuels macron est jugé négatif par les
personnes interrogées
ils s'étaient 69% à le déclarer dans un
autre sondage ifop pour le jdd le
régalien n'est pas un atout pour lui ce
qui est rare pour un président sortant
c'est son vrai point faible et c'est là
dessus que la droite l'attaquent ses
adversaires vont ils en profiter ça peut
être un vrai handicap pour lui dans la
campagne si et seulement si le sujet la
domine pourtant d annonce en grande
pompe avait été faite par emmanuel
macron arroub et cet automne ou plus
récemment à nice en début d'année a
parmi elles le doublement des policiers
sur le terrain d'ici à 2030 la
généralisation des amendes forfaitaires
au lieu des peines de moins d'un an de
prison et la dotation d'un montant de 15
milliards d'euros sur cinq ans pour la
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur il a aussi
déclaré vouloir tripler à 300 euros la
menthe pour harcèlement de rue la
création de 1500 postes supplémentaires
de cyberpatrouilleurs et l'ouverture
d'une école de formation destiné à
lutter contre les attaques numériques
celui qui n'est toujours pas candidat à
sa propre succession avait toutefois
fait des promesses pour l'avenir on va
mobiliser des forces supplémentaires on
va créer 200 brigade de gendarmerie en
milieu rural c'est ce qui va permettre
le doublement des forces de police sur
le terrain en actions pour la protection
et la sécurité d'ici à 2030 nous avons
ces cinq dernières années conformément à
l'engagement que j'avais pris réinvesti
dans notre sécurité un discours qui ne
semble pas convaincre les français sur
son bilan sécuritaire excepté peut-être
son ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qui joue les porte-paroles de
près de 68 millions de français il n'y a
pas un français qui pensent qu'il n'a
pas été un bon président de la
république il a eu 2 33 tonnes durant
son mandat celui des gilet jaune et
celui du co vide 19 le président est
celui qui a permis de traverser ces
crises des crises qui sont loin d'être
terminés qui pourrait peut-être coûté sa
réélection et emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui encore les manifestations de
gilet jaune et contre les restrictions
sanitaires continuent d'avoir lieu
chaque samedi partout dans l'hexagone